hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the thing tonight look it's a
thing and it's night okay anyway we're
kind trapped up here while this
douchenozzle down there decides to edge
with me you you're glad
oh did he actually leave I'd doubt it
but here we go what it's gone what
course is gone
I saw it get up wait Dyer mouse user
they must be waking up okay I got the
blood all of the most acid blood needs
to be heated Oh God that didn't make
sense but I don't care I'm done
questioning video game logic I was done
questioning video game logic a long time
ago but then I kept pushing at it that's
just bad news bears you know so I'll
just carry on as if everything is okay
okay hopping hopping out your back in
here
I heard that I heard that moves man oh
you can't sneak up on me
I am unstable wasn't there one in here
yeah cuz I had to hide in that closet
oh well it don't matter wait am I in the
right place it's a place with the place
with the face yeah this is it okay oh no
no it's not wait a minute wait a minute
something's not right
oh yeah the doctor's house - uh that's
where it was in the doctor's house I'm
an idiot but then again you all knew
that right enough babying around trying
to get serious and here we go
good enough close enough I hear you I
hear you moose man think it was off to
the left here or right here
up nope I was wrong but that sign say
tabularium okay never mind I'm an idiot
I spin so long since I played totes
forgotten everything that I've ever done
oh here we go this dark house yep wait
yeah I'm getting tired of that loading
screen there's got to be something else
out there for me right right right
anyway click oh yeah are those gonna
wake up and you guys pointed out that I
missed this I've been shown things that
make my eyes bleed it's not like I'm me
but I can't stop it I feel like it has
shown me the way and I'm so close I can
feel it
but I have a bit of setback I'm running
out of test subjects at work on I've
done it three and my test stuff said
have failed but to have slowly changed I
thinks my poison was some of my blood
which I call acid blood making the dead
rise from my bidding I just hope this
works because it will put me one step
closer to my final objective I'll be
moving into my castle for more work
space the town is dead and even if
someone is still alive it won't be for
too long the power I have now is really
something from another world it's really
strong and I could feel it guiding me it
wants me to do something I just don't
know what it is yet I've opened a hole
to another world probably to where the
great evil has come because it just
feels even stronger on the other side I
can move safely but God help anyone else
that tries it I'm just a shell of my
former self being controlled by the evil
I let out I'm sorry my sons and my dear
wife
the evil is ordering me to go to the
castle this is a price I must pay
because this now this evil lives in me
there we go
are you happy I missed the note so I did
a full dramatic reading just for you all
hey wait a minute I stood you guys up
what wait a minute
good stop trying that don't stop trying
now okay all right cool off man
deal with it you're no good fail hello
you turn green I think that okay a
mixture that your father used to bring
the dead back from the underworld then
now it's heated Fantasma coal what do I
do now looks like a doorway to another
world maybe some of the power my father
just found like my brother said in his
note it may lead me to the castle they
must find a way to open it even knowing
that probably what waits for me on the
other side is something really dangerous
really dangerous I have no other choice
okay so there was on another note about
no I read that one Babar
okay so um father made some type of
blood you need the blood place it on the
left pedestal and nothing can be put in
first place it's an artifact so I need
to find the artifact and then the head
I'm guessing okay so I got the blood
that's good null
but now what
excuse me you guys what I got a hand oh
it's done play never mind
Oh heard that music I hate that music so
much oh it's oh god move man
Oh guys he sends shivers up my spine I
swear hey buddy
I'm really glad that people don't
overuse mousse man because he is really
the more terrifying of the two I mean
yeah the grunts are kind of scary but oh
nothing sends shivers down my spine like
that mousse man call
[Music]
oh go away please can I make a run for
it or something is how I need to do I
don't see him oh there is go away that's
right bye-bye
oh it's just the music combined with
that it's such a perfect
Hakan okay okay
I think it's going away
well maybe is I'm okay
I'm more than okay knowing that you guys
are here with okay is exchanged we're
good to go man
I tell you this this mod for some reason
like it feels like it's pacing me like
I've been I I don't feel like I've done
a lot well actually I do feel like I've
done a lot but I don't feel like I've
gotten very far in the story which is
good because it's like really immersive
and well built I mean that outside town
outside town area could be done a little
better but amnesia wasn't meant for
outdoor environments okay so I got the
blood okay so I got the blood now I need
an artifact and then the body part from
the pure hearth to person whatever
that's supposed to mean but it doesn't
really matter because I'm moving forward
I think that house it's gotta be
something in that house that I went in
where there was nothing the strange
house the mayor's house those that door
that was locked so
I'm pretty sure there has to be
something in there right
you know Emmys it wasn't meant for
outdoor environments but this still
looks really good like no job it's very
very well done let me go back in here
just to check and try to see what's
going on oh and I know somebody has said
that it's pretty dark it's because I
don't have my lantern on most a time
because I'm running back and forth
between places that I've already been so
I I know the layout and I want to save
my stuff okay so this is where I found
the knife that's right there was
something in here that was a knife but
there was other door over here that was
mysterious know what's the deal you
can't use this item this wedding hi I'm
Anna I'm gonna head back to the pedestal
area the with all the really cool
looking lights and stuff a really well
designed area and I'm gonna see if I can
give this a try in a lot of ways this
mod reminds me of the innovative level
design that was in lost the lights I did
a let's play of loss of lights so if you
want to check out that one if you
haven't already that one well for one it
had some of the biggest scares I've ever
had in my life
I hear him but I've I haven't I have yet
to run into one
I don't know if it's just like you know
just audio there's actually a moose man
running out there I don't know I think
it's just audio but I don't scream
that might be that I don't know Oh God
okay here we go
that was the back of the barn no big
deal there and we're moving forward dad
deep into the jungle where no one
survived oh and I wanted to acknowledge
I wanted to acknowledge some people were
trying to get me to notice that the new
slender game Thunder sanatorium was
actually just a map in a in a project
that was gonna have more I did notice
that so I will play hospice when it
comes out which should be soon actually
so expect another slender I know you
guys have been begging me to play
slender play the first time I've played
slender like you're just walking through
the jungle area I didn't feel like it
was all that involved hey baby
oh do did you miss me oh yeah I noticed
that um who is another one II owe you
twins oh okay
I noticed like when I was pointing the
first one out I don't know if it was
like I didn't have the right attitude
about it or something like that but for
some reason I felt like I was missing
something too I mean it scared me it
sure did but I don't know I didn't feel
like I got into it but that
but that that second sanatorium oh that
got to me I would have played longer but
I just I had to stop because I it was
like dead midnight I was tired and I
didn't feel like having nightmares again
so that's why that happened but anyway
I'm just so um I was hoping that that
would do something and lead me towards
the next part but apparently that
something happened so I'm just gonna go
back and there are some other there are
the two other dark houses two maybe
three there are other dark houses any
way that I can that I can go to
I think I opened up the one that was
close to the barn
I believe so so that'll be interesting
to go to
oh man this place is freaking me out
I love a mod or custom story they picks
and chooses when to throw Moss wrong
because if it happens all the time it
just dumbs it down like at the end of
gary dark secrets
normally the patient was good but then
they just threw ten of them in a row at
me and the lost all its meaning this
one's good this one's very good yeah
this this one right here what is this
Jay's house who whose che doors locked
but there must be a key somewhere around
I thought I'd found a key at some point
it's not this key to something else oh
yeah I was key to the mayor's house or J
all right there's got to be another door
than a or another dark house that I'm
missing because I've been around a bit
but I haven't been everywhere I think
I've got to be one more house where I
can find that key
was that high
ah now I can go down okay ah okay maybe
I find come down here that oh no oh
sorry about this ladies and gentlemen
unfortunately I'm gonna have to end the
episode here thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye